[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous faites un objet magique
doit punir les âmes un pur des
châtiments extrêmement cruelle je ne
vais pas révéler évidemment la teneur
[Musique]
e
oui
le mal le parfum des hommes jon manga
[Musique]
rapport
hasta la vista est ce qu'on met la
pédagogie ont tous eu par godard
candidats et à mal quelques
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
il
m
[Applaudissements]
jamais
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa batterie qui va bien il n'y a qu'un
mec qui va il n' y est
[Musique]
c
vie
de mon coin
à ma chérie ce toit qu'un conseil sur
mes coiffure alors en fait à la boule
que je fasse ça c'est le dimanche soir
qu'on fait pourquoi je fais de tous les
cheveux parce que on sait bleus dans ma
vie ces bleus dans mon coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez compter quelques jours j'ai
instruit angéla vous permet j'ai appris
que l'on peut se filmer tous les deux
regardez là donc on n'a pas la gastro
[Musique]